this is a really high stakes case not
only is it personal between angelina and
brad there is a lot of money at stake
here e.t has obtained brad's lawsuit
which accuses angelina of selling their
french vineyard to a russian businessman
without the actor's consent the couple
bought the 1200 acre property estimated
to be worth 162 million back in 2008.
brad's attorney says the vineyard became
pitt's passion and he helped grow it
into a multi-million dollar
international success story legal expert
rachel stockman says brad claims he put
sweat equity into the estate brad is
saying i wanted to continue to run this
business and continue to grow it so down
the line if i wanted to sell it it could
have been worth even more you filed this
lawsuit basically saying i want damages
and i want the court to declare
your sale of your portion of the
vineyard null and voice brad wants a
trial by jury and kelly clarkson wants a
name change
in the wake of her divorce from brandon
blackstock kelly's filed court documents
asking to go by kelly brienne her middle
name a source tells e.t the title of the
kelly clarkson show will remain the same
it's a great title the 39 year old
explained my new name more fully
reflects who i am it may also be a way
to distance herself from her father
steven michael
clarkson love
her myself ballad piece by piece was
about their contentious relationship
[Music]